uh thank you yes sir yes I'm joined in
the studio by Alex gerford and his kids
yes you have to put your daughter on
your left so a little higher there we go
this little lady uh has ringed the Bell
tonight yes how did you enjoy that
oh thumbs up
so Alex you are this senior financial
advisor at Edward Jones and I've learned
a lot of things about you that if you
made a lot of contributions to the world
chairs and especially the community in
St Louis but you're also the founder of
a very important uh chess program and
chess tournament the Saint Louis
corporate chess League please tell tell
us a little bit about this yeah thank
you I'll I'll talk about the corporate
League I do just want to say first and
foremost that my relationship with chess
is definitely as a fan and so seeing the
Karen's cup back here again every year I
bring my kids and we really have a good
time being here so what um you know Dr
Jeannie and and Rex have done to bring
in the best talent is really exciting
here in St Louis and it really is
amazing to see the connections that the
that chess can have and so my idea
around having chess and corporations
come together about seven years ago has
really taken off it's been it's been
amazing to see here in St Louis how much
interest that that people love
networking competing having fun over the
game of chess and so it was kind of an
idea that came up with a friend of mine
and we were talking about like corporate
softball leagues and I just kind of had
the idea well what about a corporate
chess league and from there was able to
share with the St Louis chess club and
they've taken it certainly to amazing
Heights where we have great competition
great organization of the tournament and
it's been a lot of fun
well you're the captain emeritus of your
own team so who actually won the last
season and tell us a little bit about
the next season and what businesses
participated before in them sure so this
season I have to tip my hat to our
friends over at Enterprise they won the
the 2023 spring spring league and Edward
Jones came in second place and then some
of our other other competitors were
Ascension Healthcare Enterprise
worldwide technology we had Charles
Schwab making their debut Reuben Brown
and then also the St Louis chess club
actually fielded a team this year so
eight teams participated in all and it
was a great competition but Enterprise
wound up taking the the top honors for
the spring season
what do they have to
it's it's really easy to go on to the St
Louis chess club website and look under
the corporate chess League logo be able
to sign up and next season already we're
bringing on Boeing I think two other
teams have already contacted me and and
interested in it and so if if you're
interested in competing you know get a
team together of five or six people and
and come out it's a great opportunity to
not just the the networking side but the
relationship that chess can have with
strategic thinking problem solving
pattern recognition can really be
something that goes I mean across any
company that is going to be something
that will be good for your your
corporation and so encourage you to to
sign up and and come out and compete I
also said maybe bonding because it's it
can help it could be a team building
event absolutely I mean being able to
have some of those Fierce battles
encouraging your your colleague makes it
a lot of fun yes and let's have a look
at the upcoming events right on your
screen you have the the dates
of the of the next events 2023
fall dates
so we're on a little bit of a break
right now over the summer time but yes
get those uh get online sign up before
September 28th when the pieces will be
flying again we'd love to have more
teams more competitors the cross
industry idea sharing that just
naturally and organically comes out of
the corporate chess League time and
there's hey there's a few Refreshments a
few beverages that that we share as well
and so it really makes it for a good
time overall at the the corporate chess
league and I think that we are going to
have a replay of a very beautiful moment
where your daughter rang the bell and
but how did you choose it actually it
was going down
oh that's great well I mean being the
Karen's cup and getting to be here with
with our family I thought it'd be
appropriate and fun for my daughter to
get to step up there which they're both
excited that next week they will be here
at chess Camp all week so they'll both
be here participating with that so for
those parents that are out there if
you're still looking for something for
your your young kids to do that's going
to benefit them over the summer time the
the St Louis chess club camps are are
going to be a lot of fun so I assume
they both play who is who is stronger
we won't reveal this I think I think
I'll stay out of that one next question
well I have one last question for you
Alex that's I also know that you are
involved in the case such as Club can
you tell us more about that sure my wife
and I have been involved with the kaisa
club for a number of years now and it is
for those that are interested in
supporting the educational benefits as
well as the the cultural exhibitions
that we see here in St Louis where the
it's an annual gift of a thousand
dollars a year and as a result of that
gift you're really able to support the
the massive amount of student education
curriculum that the St Louis chess club
provides and there are some really
really cool things that you get to do as
well being able to go to some of the
opening exhibitions getting to go to
certain tournaments getting some behind
the scenes access at times and so it's a
great way to support St Louis chess and
and everything that we're involved with
here and we've really loved being a part
of it and getting to bring our family as
well to various events and so and kaisa
being I believe the the goddess of of
Chess and so historical it's kind of a
nice connection really cool thank you so
much thank you guys so looking forward
to play a game of chess against you
thank you thank you Alex and indeed I'm
happy to join you also at the Kaiser
chess club